here's one what made you realize one of
your guys
was really good to go or was not up the
standard
not necessarily big things but micro
actions or decisions that set
something off in your mind
well i had a lot of guys work under me
over the years and
i mean i really think that you know all
my brothers and the teams
every one of them is good to go even the
guys i didn't get along with i'd still
give my wife for him in a second doesn't
matter
but uh one thing that sticks out to me
was biggles
but it was ryan job because you know i
i don't i guess i could have been more
like nice or whatever
but i'm like man you look like you're
[ __ ] fat
you better get in [ __ ] shape but i'm
gonna i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
i'm not gonna like rate you up i don't
even know how to do that
i'm gonna i'm gonna just physically kill
you and man
you know i didn't even know if he was in
good shape or not because some people
you can't tell
yeah they're like look at that guy and
then he just knocks [ __ ] out yeah people
that
iron marshmallow yeah and man that kid
did
i mean he really really did and like all
of a sudden i'm like
chum well i didn't say that i was like
hmm
i you know so that was like yeah that
was like my praise like yeah
yeah whatever you can i praise from okay
on the next one on the next thing
yeah yeah but i mean that was really
good
you know i remember one of my guys
uh lost a piece of equipment one time
and
you know i was kind of upset with him
but it just made me realize
that you know if we're making a mistake
maybe it's not this guy's fault maybe
it's my fault maybe it's everyone's
fault as a
as a team because at the end of the day
it's all of us
so maybe we want to take a day or two
off
you know and that kind of helped and you
know we handled it but
i mean another one of my guys he uh
it was christmas and he left left a
piece of equipment open or he didn't
lock something and i mean it wasn't a
big deal i could have corrected it right
there
but the guys are just taking off on
christmas leave and
i was had nowhere to go so i was
drinking beers in the team area
so i just walked around checking [ __ ]
out and sure enough
so i called the guy and he was like
three or four hundred miles into
his drive to a western state for
christmas i'm like
he goes oh i'm sorry i'm like yeah no
problem man all right so turn around now
and i'll be waiting for you
his dead silence on the phone he's like
what yeah
yeah so he drove all the way back
and i was standing there it's like four
in the morning now and i was like
it was pretty liquored up by then and
just fuming
but he's like hey i'm sorry you learn a
lesson yep
okay have a good leave and i'm sure
i'm positive you never did that again
that'll do it
you know yeah it's kind of a dink move i
guess but
you know i figured it was the thing to
do he who suffers
remembers yeah
yeah it's uh it's
the the the single teams when you're
when you're just
working with guys all the time you
definitely start to pick up
things you can indicate okay yeah this
guy's this guy's stepping up you know
that's what i always noticed
when when things are going sideways like
in a training operation and you see a
guy that's starting to step up
you know that was always a good sign
absolutely you know absolutely like he's
gonna he's gonna handle something it's
like
that's when you train decentralized
commands that's where you gotta let guys
make mistakes and screw things up
because you know the less you you know
the more you sweat and
training unless you bleed more no doubt
about that one